when we say Lehman moment we are
thinking epic collapse is that unfair to
what some of the other companies have
been going through it's a massively
overused phrase if you look it up on
google and you tie the words either
Lehman or Glencore to it you will see
hundreds of thousands of examples of
people claiming that Volkswagen is a
Lehman moments and Glencore azzolini
moment they're not the banking industry
is still suffering the shock waves of
Lehman from 2008 the amount of
regulation the new capital they have to
have in store is a massive sea change
for an entire industry no matter wha
with Volkswagen it is not going to kill
the auto industry it is not going to
change the auto industry it might lead
to the end of diesel engines but that
was coming anyway with the rise of
electric vehicles similarly for Glencore
being an integrated commodities company
digging stuff out of the ground and
trading on the financial markets Glenn
cause problems do not prove that that
model is not viable going forward the
other main thing is lehman was really
quick I mean really quick yes the
markets were in difficulties for a while
but its CEO Dick Fuld was convinced
absolutely convinced that liquidity was
not overly an issue for his bank which
is why he didn't seek a buyer to get
himself out of trouble one minute Lehman
was there bang the next day it was gone
and you saw all his employees carrying
cardboard boxes of belongings out of the
bank completely shell-shocked now the
Volkswagen o Glencoe are in the same
league of speed or industry wild
severity mark is there a more apt
comparison when you look back at the
history of Commerce the long history of
Commerce is there a better comparison we
should be making here for Glencore and
for Volkswagen corporate malfeasance for
Volkswagen there are you know history is
littered with examples of accounting
fraud of you know General Motors yet
with its problems and having to do a
recall toyota will it stick accelerate a
problem there more of the category
that's there for volkswagen glenn calls
a different case Glencore is tied to the
commodities market and anyone who's been
watching commodity prices this year
cannot be surprised that a company
that's buried in that industry it kind
of symbolizes what being a full-scale
commodities company is you can't really
be surprised
the glencoe is in trouble uh mark we
can't be surprised that Glencore is in
trouble but as we mentioned about the
Lehman moment Lehman was in a class by
itself so again I go back to I guess
piggybacking my first question the
comparisons that are being made is that
just a little bit overkill at this point
or people just getting ahead of
themselves it's a little lazy as the
honest truth and I think I'm as guilty
of it as any other scribble editor it's
a really nice evocative scary phrase to
reach for to say that some companies is
going to arrive at a lemur moment it was
used for Greece as well you know was
Greece at its Lima moment when it was in
in trouble it couldn't get its bailout
package your head it is laziness it's an
attempt to try and encapsulate a lot of
different factors in a snappy phrase but
it misses a lot of points you know
another thing about Lehman it was in
denial the entire Bank was in denial
about where it was headed if you
contrast what happen with Lehman with
Merrill Lynch where John Thain found the
warm comforting embrace of Bank of
America and sold his bank if Nicky fault
had done the same thing lehman brothers
would still be alive in some way shape
or form today and that really isn't the
case so I think that over using the
phrase Lehman moment not only is it lazy
it distracts from the uniqueness of that
situation the massive repercussions that
were still seeing and honestly it was a
really sad event in financial history
let me just ask you maybe lastly hear
about the vivid picture that you painted
arrow remind us of people leaving those
buildings with cardboard boxes what have
we learned from that I mean you talked
about how quickly these companies have
responded Glencore Volkswagen we saw big
leadership changes there in mere days
after this was discovered have we
learned lessons from what had with
Lehman that are applicable to other
companies I think crisis management is
now in every CEO and chairman and boards
toolbox as something they go to very
quickly I don't think we're quite where
we need to be in terms of admitting
things as quickly as company should
sometimes but certainly when it is clear
that there is a big problem I think
companies are much better than our
acknowledging it
much quicker to fire the CEO if it's
clear that something happened on his or
hair watch and someone needs to take
responsibility for it and also what
we're seeing with glencore is a
recognition that if it turns out that
investors aren't happy with the state of
your balance sheet given what's
happening in your industry you better
move quickly to address those fears and
that's exactly what Glencore is done
this week it's planning asset sales it's
raising equity it's telling people it's
going to get its debt down its
acknowledging that the commodities
business is not what it was 12 months
ago and it's doing something about it so
I think you're absolutely right
companies are much quicker now to try
and get ahead of the curve rather than
being overtaken by events both in terms
of changing peso know when they need to
and in changing their financial
structure and that's appropriate